[Music]
police officers in Georgia are being
celebrated for going above and beyond to
make a little girl's birthday
extra-special body camera video shows
the officers surprising her mother with
a cake for the girl's first birthday the
they first met the woman when she was
outside in the cold trying to get home
our lead national correspondent David
Begg now is here David what happened
next
such I'll need a little good news this
morning we did will uplift please look
it happened back in January but we know
about it today because the police
department just posted it on its
Facebook page now the officers didn't
tell their supervisors what they did it
was a routine audit of the officers body
camera that's how a police supervisor
came across it and that's how the
officers kindness was exposed ma'am
were you trying to get to that is the
voice of Sergeant Nick boney
you're welcome
hey come here we'll give you my credit
card go get her a birthday cake with a
number one candle I think they got any
in there officer Jimmy Wilson is the one
asked to go find a cake she had
obviously purchased everything that she
could afford that was just something
that a one-year-old should have a
birthday cake your baby just turn one
today yeah when they arrived at the
house the lady asked the officer yeah
actually we got a little surprise
Oh Thank You officer will ski problem
there's her cake we say the little girls
when they ran up to give us a hug and
stuff that was just it was just like as
part of the family the officers stayed
and played and then they saying
[Music]
that wasn't that right yeah you're a kid
and you know it's not the first time
sergeant Boni has been recognized in
2013 he was named officer of the year
and later honored with the Medal of
Valor for saving the lives of five
firefighters taken hostage a medical
call yes oh yeah above and beyond audit
that's a random murder David thank you